[Musique]
le maire de coignières veut protéger son
intercommunalité
la ville fait partie de la communauté de
communes des étangs forte de 38 mille
habitants comprenant maurepas les
bréviaires les essarts le roi et le
perray en yvelines
pas question d'y toucher alors que le
préfet de région a présenté lui un
projet d'intercommunalité à huit cent
mille habitants
je suis dans une politique commune à
taille humaine où les élus sont pas
encore trop éloigné on va dire de la
ville d'istres et locaux à partir de là
et bien c'est une cause et de communes
donc il ya une dimension qui vous
convient parfaitement
la communauté d'agglomération qu'on nous
propose nous imposera tout sur le plan
financier n'en parlons pas je sais par
expérience que dès l'instant où les
structures sur les normes ou soros les
impôts locaux augmentent en septembre
dernier un collectif s'est créé pour
défendre la communauté de communes des
étangs une défense qui passe par une
consultation populaire
ce dimanche les coignet rien sont
appelés aux urnes pour voter oui ou non
à cette question souhaitez-vous la
préservation de la communauté de
communes des étangs dans son périmètre
actuel
je souhaite et je veux que c'est ce qu
espèrent que la rue afin de répondre de
façon massive à cette réhabilitation
d'une part parce que c'est important
pour la survie de croisière
mais en démocratie mais je pense
également je pense donc mes administrés
ont le droit d'user leurs avis je dirais
sur une affaire qui va complètement
bouleverser leur existence
deux bureaux de vote seront ouverts l'un
en mairie l'autre à l'école bouvet les
résultats de la consultation seront
transmis au préfet de région
sa décision concernant
l'intercommunalité élargie devrait être
rendu en février 2015
et dès ce vendredi soir la mairie de
coignières organise une réunion publique
d'information
[Musique]
tonya kinzinger alias jessica dans la
série sous le soleil a rejoint la chaîne
nrj 12 pour présenter la nouvelle saison
de la star academy avec matthieu
delormeau ils présenteront chaque jeudi
en direct le prince où les élèves seront
jugés aux côtés de stars en france est
rare d'avoir un chanteur qui s'élançait
ou un acteur qui sait danser et chanter
aux états unis déjà dans le culture
d'avoir cette polyvalence mais ça vient
petit à petit en france et j'y suis ravi
ça permet aussi parfois de se séparer
vous verrez dans le plateau sera pas
forcément toujours en somme une équipe
peut faire un lancement et pas l'autre
ça permet d'avoir effectivement toutes
les interviews américaine
ce sera avec des artistes internationaux
ce sera pour tenir à la partie plus de
française pour moi les élèves
intégreront la star academy pour la
neuvième saison de l'émission jeudi soir
les académiciens seront révélés au
public lors du premier prime
ils découvriront alors le château de la
jeunesse situé à châteaufort
magnifiquement il a fait très froid un
compte n'y était photo là bas il en a
fait des plateaux de la semaine dernière
n'a pas à moi je la trouve très belle
année entièrement refaite
très très moderne tout dans un look
musique jeunes un peu tourner on va dire
moi compris ce château ils ont tourné et
elle est très très belle je penserai à
l'écran sera ajouté même si certains
couleur je n'aurais pas choisi chez moi
je les ai repéré les lieux forcément je
me suis bon à ce qu'ils vont pouvoir
aller courir dans wow quel endroit s'il
pleut parce qu'on a un abri pour pouvoir
travailler qui est des couleurs vives
c'est allé voir à l'entrée dans très dur
il ya une couleur qui sauf réveil ça ne
motive pas ouais ça motive ça motive ce
que c'est une couleur très une couleur
sang
après c'est la nature tout comme issam
dehors donc c'est l'hiver ouais la neige
et où ça va coûter grave pour ajuster
couvrir c'est tout vous aurez sûrement
reconnu pascal l'ancien grand frère de
tf1
reconverti en coach sportif et mental
mais officiant toujours dans la télé
réalité ou pas le but c'est qu'ils
puissent tous des pastous et tout parce
qu'il ya aussi des filles que tout le
monde puisse dépasser ses propres
limites
donc ça s'écoute intéressant donc je
vais tester très rapidement limites de
chacun et puis le but c'est moi qui
puisse aller le plus loin possible aussi
bien dans le sport que dans la tête
parce que ça c'est important il faut
qu'ils avaient un mental très très fort
et pour que les rendez vous le jeudi 6
décembre sur nrj 12 pour enfin découvrir
le nouvel intérieur du château de la
jeunesse à châteaufort qui sont
consacrés
[Musique]